Jake Paul
has announced his next fight in his Jake
Paul versus Nate Diaz absolutely
brilliant now you called for this years
ago I wanted this years ago this was the
fight and I do think that losing to
Tommy takes away a little of the steam
but the fact that Nate isn't a boxer
makes us still curious and I think that
the people who hate Jake
still want to see an MMA guy beat him uh
yeah right because the beef was always
he was driving his wedge between the MMA
community and the boxing community and
he was trying to beat up on Dana and
beating up on the UFC and you got to pay
him whatever and you know maybe Jake
really cares about it maybe he doesn't
give a [__] who knows but brilliant way
of like drumming up interest
so I think people would like to see an
MMA guy beat up Jake especially a guy as
popular and beloved as Nate Diaz yeah
smart move yeah also thanks for being a
bad [__] yeah and Nate will help
on the promo you don't have to do the
heavy lifting like Tommy Fury had to do
all the [__] lifting yeah Nate is
just Nate and you're gonna be amazed
yeah yeah dude their promo is going to
be so good yeah yeah I mean yeah it was
interesting I was trying to guess what
it was because
Jake's manager hit me yesterday and he
was like hey
um you know want to talk to you about
our next fight and I was like I didn't
even want to ask who it was because I
was like you're not going to tell me
yeah but then they're like and uh we
want to get Amanda Serrano we'd love to
get Amanda Serrano on the Pod if you
guys have time to ask Ron was that girl
that fought on the undercover right that
was a great fight he's great she's
[__] awesome and um and I was just
thinking who the [__] is it is it
another Tommy fight I don't think people
have any interest in that yeah but
getting Nate
big get they [__] find a way bro a
lot of people wrote them off they were
like it's over for him it's done how
would you think that because he's an
Entertainer not a boxer he's an
Entertainer who is boxing right now yeah
so he will the entertainment is the
boxing is like the vehicle for him to
entertain so keep on going like if Floyd
Mayweather lost that's a good point
that's an important distinction to make
we are watching the thing that is most
entertaining if he agreed to sign on a
fight
uh to fight
um Prince Harry's wife oh yeah Megan
Meghan Markle yeah we gonna watch yeah
it's not about like his rise to super
stardom it's not about his rise to the
belt or pound for pound it's about what
is the most entertaining I watched Jake
beat this [__] out of Meghan Markle bro
what did you do you think he's gonna
beat the shatter yeah I don't know I
feel like she got it not Meghan Markle
bro you think she's not grounds I don't
know man I think she's doubled the royal
family for a long time she's like put up
with them she couldn't put up with them
she tapped out yeah she submitted very
quickly good movement though good
movement oh they want to know what color
the kid is she submit withdrew from the
league took her whole team with her
chief chief [__] Tapped Out the
hardest why can't you ask what color the
[__] kid is bro oh
why can't you ask why is that you're
talking about Indian India yeah that's
the most important thing for us say that
because yo because the most important
that Chris said it the most important
thing for us is how light is this baby
well that's an Indian ass thing with
black people they want to know as well
which is hilarious
from the Indian side you could say
there's some Imperial [__] but light
skin is very favored Anglo features in
general are favored in most minority
communities it seems no I I was told
obviously there's like Colonial racism
is attached to that but I think it's
also uh
um
hmm like there's a class system based on
where you're doing your work so if
you're in the fields picking rice all
day in the Philippines you're going to
be dark if you're a royalty you're
inside you're going to be more fair
skinned yeah so having fair skin people
immediately go well that [__]
ain't pick a rice yeah you probably got
money yeah so I definitely believe that
there is uh Colonial subconscious yeah
but I think even before white people got
to this part of the world there was
still a way yeah to see who had money
and who didn't based on how dark you
were because if you didn't you were
probably out there in the sun yeah
that's interesting assuming to that
point the first time I went to India I
was 15 I was fatter than I am now like a
chubby little [__] yeah light
skin in my school nobody thought I was
cute in India they thought I was the
cutest kid in the world because I was
heavier which I think to them does
signify he's Rich he got money on
subconsciously and then I was
light-skinned and then I went back when
I was skinnier and darker and I remember
one of my cousins being like oh man you
were so much cuter back then no yeah
cousin yeah yeah no dude cousin not good
enough looking to [__] though too ugly
to [__] dude cousin all right hey little
boy if he was better looking he might
catch the dick but all right guys we
gotta take a break from this exclusive
patreon clip because honestly your
rolling skills are trash you're horrible
at it it's an embarrassment the girl
that you're rolling up with trying to
set the mood that thing that you rolled
up it's only burning on one side it's
falling apart it's soggy it's horrible
the date is ruined she's going home you
get nothing okay well purple rose supply
has fixed that problem for you how how
they've fixed it well they fixed it with
this device right here they cannagar
okay this right here is going to do all
that beautiful setup for those rolls you
put all of your tobacco into here close
it up stuff it in all five hopefully
this goes well you'll be doing that
later as well and you have the perfect
roll in there for you to drop in your
papers your Backwoods whatever you want
I'm telling you purple rose supply has
got your back this is how you're gonna
smoke and the beautiful thing about it
is when it's actually rolled correctly
when the tobacco is laid in there
properly
is going to last for 30 minutes when
you're smoking and think about that
plenty of time to rinse that beautiful
woman or man up in your life so
you go to purpleroadsupply.com flagrant
and use the promo code flagrant you're
going to get 15 off your order I would
do it right now why not wait why waste
any more time also let's get back to
this exclusive patreon clip join the
[__] Army at patreon.com flagrant you
get a new episode of flavor every single
week with that peace oh there's that
other fight that I want to see tank and
Ryan Garcia I want to see that that's
going to be a fun fight I think it's
gonna be a great fight where's that
fight Mark can you look and see Vegas I
believe is it it feels like it should be
in Vegas when is that I'd like to go
April 22nd oh [__] I know yeah I got a
what's that club Comedy Works oh sick
yeah yeah it's gonna be great but now
which one are you doing in Denver
downtown they're both great by the way
oh I heard the other one was not great
so I moved all the shows downtown on my
way downtown the other one is great too
oh really yeah it's just it's bigger and
it's like uh
yeah it's just it's it's a bigger room
The Comedy Works downtown is like this
incredibly intimate it's like carved
into stone it feels really it's just a
yeah it's like it should be something
out of like Gringotts bank or whatever
yeah yeah thing is in Harry Potter ring
Gods yeah Gringotts yeah so
great Club but the other one is also
great like I think I remember loving the
other one remember the uh yeah so but
both those [__] things are excited to
do that yeah you're doing that that's
this coming weekend next weekend oh yeah
yeah next weekend yeah so April 22nd in
Vegas where the fighters oh man we gotta
watch that one um
it's kind of crazy did you see this
prank with the kid that pranked the old
lady sorry real quick who do you think
wins oh yeah I think the tank wins I
think tank is like an incredibly Elite
fighter and I think that people's
interest in boxing is waning a bit right
now with the rise of UFC yeah and uh I
think if he was in
if we're looking at like someone in his
Heyday the Heyday boxing I think that he
would be up there with the likes of
I mean
I don't know maybe at this point in his
career right now saying Floyd might be a
lot but like incredibly powerful and
impressive for his size yeah Power at
that size yeah yeah yeah knockout guy
Garcia seems to have power too though
definitely does he says I saw him doing
a bunch of Instagram [__] and I was like
oh he's like a good looking kid I was
like I was just some pretty boy but it
seems like a box to it yeah and he he
embraced YouTube and he embraced social
media early yeah and he like builds up
his stardom in that way and it was
really smart wonder if these fights get
a bump because of the Jake Paul fights
like I had never seen a boxing match
before a YouTube boxing match really I'd
never like I mean I was like yeah I was
a kid when any of the good Fighters back
in the day were fighting like wow I
never watched like uh Canelo fight or
any of those yeah and so like yeah that
was the first one that I was like I
bought the fight and I watched it I
think if you buy a a YouTube boxing
match and you really enjoy it and then
you become as like involved in a
Fighter's life yeah as you do with these
YouTubers then yeah that makes sense and
then Ryan Garcia is giving you the
opportunity tank maybe not as much but
Brian has a great social media presence
100 and like I bought a fight because of
Jake Paul and now I'm kind of like
interested in boxing as well check it
out so now I'm curious about this fight
yeah yeah I wonder how many people would
be like me that would be like I'm gonna
buy this fight because now I'm a boxing
fan I hope a lot I you know I admire
these guys for getting in there I mean
even the guy uh poeton uh perdera the
guy that um that is he just beat like
I'm so [__] happy as he beat him
and at the same time
I have well I've always had a lot of
respects on him but like he's also a
likable figure yeah like if you look at
his stuff yeah he's kind of funny he's
not like a real [__] he trolls him a
little bit but is he's also trolling
everybody's going back at it and it's
like you know I don't know it was one of
those those like after a few days where
like the excitement of Izzy finally
getting it had passed yeah
I felt like
they both can just kind of move on and
they both have the respect and the ego
is done I was glad when I read he's
going to move up to light heavyweight
because I was like oh I could root for
him yeah middleweight I got it crazy 100
everywhere and I can root for this guy
this is like a great he's a [__]
monster oh yeah he seems like not
whatever not like a [__] not
trolling for no reason just to get views
he's just a [__] War him going to the
Favela and like the tribal outfit that
[__] was fire yeah people couldn't
really recognize how far it was until
now yeah yeah we had to be like nah that
[__] is being nice with a bow and arrow
and actually a real [__] bow and
arrow yeah as far yeah he's legit